As you spend the majority of your time with your coworkers,...
...love is bound to flourish.
Not only are you more aware of their personalities,...
...but you have an established chemistry and lots in common.
Here are some helpful tips on making sure love's labor's not lost.
Avoid the boss.
While dating a colleague is something you might be considering,...
...going for your boss is something we cannot recommend.
They may be attractive and just the type of person you've been searching for,...
...but there could be serious fallout.
You don't want every promotion or opportunity you're given...
...to be waved off by your coworkers as simply a perk of going steady with the chief.
Discretion is your friend.
Yes, the gooey feeling of finding the right someone...
...can make us want to grab a megaphone and connect it to an amp turned up to 11.
But sometimes being discreet is the proper way to go.
There may be some past romantic conflicts between colleagues that you are unaware of.
And creating an environment of jealousy and resentment is something best avoided.
Similarly, favoring your newly found friend...
...could lead to political problems further down the line.
Finally, keep your intentions honest.
You don't want to get into something with the promise of it being serious...
...if you're not quite ready for that level of commitment.
Calling it off after a short run may be fine for you,...
...but it could leave the other party confused and lost.
Be honest from the start and you're bound to not only have a less stressful time,...
...but in case it doesn't work out, the dark cloud of pure tension won't be an issue.
This guide was brought to you by Monster.
For more advice, jobs and career tools, visit monster.co.uk.